WE'LL SEE IF THAT HAPPENS.
OF COURSE IT WON'T.
WE'LL FOLLOW IT AND WE'LL TELL
YOU WHAT HAPPENS.
MEANWHILE, MS-13 HAS BEEN
TERRORIZING ORDINARY PEOPLE,
MOSTLY IMMIGRANTS IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR YEARS.
IT'S THE DEADLIEST GANG IN
AMERICA AND SEEMS TO BE TURNING
ITS SIGHTS AGAINST AMERICAN
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
IN RECENT WEEKS, LONG ISLAND
POLICE HAVE ARRESTED SEVERAL
GANG MEMBERS AND LEADERS ARE
TELLING THEIR FOOT SHOULDERS,
IT'S TIME TO TAKE THE STREET
BACK AND SHOOT A COP LIKE WE DO
IN EL SALVADOR.
THEY SHOULD A LOT OF COPS IN
EL SALVADOR, THEY RUN THE
COUNTRY.
PATRICK RYDER IS COMMISSIONER OF
THE NASSAU POLICE DEPARTMENT.
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF MS-13 IS UP
UNTIL NOW, THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF CRIMES IN HIGH-PROFILE
KILLINGS, BUT THEY HAVEN'T
TARGETED LAW ENFORCEMENT.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S CHANGING?
>> WE GOT OUR THREAT LAST
WEDNESDAY, THEY DECIDED THEY
WERE GOING TO PUT OUT NOTICE TO
THEIR FOOT SOLDIERS THAT YOU
WOULD TAKE A COPS LIFE JUST LIKE
THEY DO IN EL SALVADOR.
>> Tucker: WHY THE CHANGE?
>> THEY DON'T LIKE THE FACT THAT
WE'VE INCREASED OUR ENFORCEMENT,
WE ARE GOING AFTER MS-13 AND ALL
OUR GANGS, THEY DECIDED THEY
WOULD ACT BACK.
IN RETURN, WE ARE GOING TO ACT
BACK.
>> Tucker: WHERE THESE PEOPLE
COMING FROM?
>> MOST ARE CROSSING FROM THE
BORDER OF MEXICO AND TEXAS.
THEY FIND THEIR WAY UP INTO THE
NEW YORK AREA WHERE THERE IS
WORK FOR MOST MIGRANT WORKERS,
BUT AGAIN, THOSE WHO DON'T JOIN
THE GANG GET THREATENED BY THE
GETTING TO JOIN IT.
THEY GO AFTER THE YOUNG KIDS.
>> Tucker: YOU MAY HAVE MISSED
THIS, BUT HERE IN WASHINGTON,
MS-13 HAS HAD SOME HIGH-PROFILE
DEFENDERS WHO HAVE SAID IT'S
WRONG, IT'S A MORAL       IMMORL
WRONG, IT'S A MORAL       IMMOR.
HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> I SPENT A LOT OF TIMES IN THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY AND THESE
LEADERS IN THE COMMUNITY, THEY
DON'T WANT THEM THERE.
THEY WANT NO PART OF THEM IN
THEIR COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT THEY ARE
GIVEN A WITH THEIR OWN AND ARE
PROTECTED BECAUSE THEY THREATEN
OTHERS AND NOW THEY'VE TAKEN THE
THREAT TO US.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE IT BACK TO
THEM.
>> Tucker: I WENT TO
EL SALVADOR LAST SUMMER AND
THAT'S A HOLDING FACILITY WITH
MS-13 MEMBERS.
MS-13 HAS A HUGE ROLE IN EFFECT
RUNNING EL SALVADOR.
IT'S A PRETTY BIG OPERATION.
THEY KILL COPS REGULARLY THEIR
INPUT AND MANY OTHERS ON THE
TAKE.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THE GANG
METASTASIZING AND TURNING REALLY
VIOLENT?
DO YOU THINK THEY COULD BE
PREDICTING THE FUTURE?
>> BOTH OF THE THREATS WERE
RECEIVED WERE CREDIBLE.
WE ARE CONCERNED OBVIOUSLY FOR
THE OFFICER'S SAFETY, ALL OF OUR
OFFICERS BOTH HERE AND IN THE
COUNTRY.
WHATEVER COLOR UNIFORM YOU WEAR,
WE HAVE TO DEFEND THAT.
WE ARE THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE
IN THIS COUNTRY FROM THESE GANG
MEMBERS THAT WANT TO TAKE --
START ENFORCING THEIR VIOLENCE.
WE HAVE TO BRING BACK A MESSAGE
TO THEM, THAT WILL NOT BE
ACCEPTED.
>> Tucker: IF YOU MAINTAIN